citizens of the reject Nation it's me Tara
Erickson alongside this guy we're gonna watch
How to Train Your Dragon I love dragons I wrote a
kid's book that had a dragon in it so like I love
me some dragons now listen neither of us have
watched this wait go ahead say your story you
might have I have seen this once I don't recall
it he doesn't remember story of Greg was you know
yeah oh yeah he probably fell asleep he's eating
popcorn I remember being kind of cute but everyone
Raves about this Trilogy like it's the second
coming of Christ so I I'm like I don't know what
that emotion is with this Trilogy so I want I want
to watch it again just don't remember any anything
that happens in it so yeah I was like yeah I wanna
I wanna know I am ready I've never seen it don't
forget you guys need to leave like you need to
get on the computer you need to leave a comment
you need to leave some fun comments and also ring
the bell ring the bells just subscribe because if
you're not already subscribed I don't know what
you're doing and also don't forget to join patreon
so you can watch our full entire reaction on there
on patreon so come on get pledging and get on get
on that boat man Greg and John cover several shows
over there exclusively with reaction highlights
and watch alongs included over at patreon so
now I think that we're ready to get into it
this is Burke it's 12 days north of hopeless and a
few degrees south of freezing to death my Village
and it's been here for Seven Generations but
every single building is new the only problems
are the passes oh my God we have dragons dragons
cool my name's hiccup Bears believe a hideous
name Will frighten off gnomes and trolls like
our Charming Viking demeanor wouldn't do that
wait is his name hecka hiccup okay I recall that
what are you doing out get inside that's stoic the
vast chief of the tribe when he was a baby he
popped a dragon's head clean off its shoulders
Jesus oh nice are you enjoying the party uh
Craig Ferguson meet head with attitude and
interchangeable hands is Goblin I've
been his Apprentice ever since I was
little well little Earth I love these
like handheld shots that they do yeah
it's awesome oh and that's fish legs it's not
loud the twins rough done and tough nuts and
hello oh my gosh two minutes I'll kill a
dragon my life will get infinitely better
you can't swing an ax you can't throw one of
these you don't even know one of these are
will throw it for me if you ever want to
get out there to fight dragons you need to
eat this being a young white man his voice
is perfect yeah it's great there's the
Monstrous Nightmare only the best Vikings
go after those they have this nasty habit
of setting themselves on fire whoa cool but the
Ultimate Prize is the Dragon no one's ever seen
whoa a Night Fury that's a dope name
oh I wonder how much research went
into the set designs for this
stuff it feels very detailed
remind yourself the Devils still have some juice
in them yeah it feels like it's an animated
version of Game of Thrones like sequences right
now give me something to shoot at give me some
give me something I'd be so scared if I was in his
position I wouldn't I'd be like
come hang out you guys are cool
oh great shot
[Applause]
yes I hit it did anybody see that oh oh
[Music]
it's cool how he looks so
large amongst other humans
but then with the dragons it feels small yeah
just a couple of punches and then he's off
oh buddy sorry Dad
remembering some minor stuff like they
were father and son it's coming back to
mind winter is almost here and I have an
entire Village to feed winter is coming
between you and me the village could do
with a little less feeding don't you think
I can't stop myself I see a dragon and I have to
just kill it you know it's who I am Dad it's like
when the athlete has a son who's a nerd yeah if
we find the nest and destroy it the dragons will
leave they'll find another hole what Vikings
it's an occupational hazard now who's with me
today
he'd be killed before you let the first dragon out
of its cage oh you don't know that I do know that
no you don't know that the voiceover work seems
so natural even as a boy I knew what it was what
I had to become hiccup is not that boy you can't
stop I'm stoic you can only prepare him his name
is actually Stoke so lose their knife for the
mug no not me I managed to lose an entire Dragon
oh I've been there man yeah
yeah
what is this like a scary deep Trail he's never
seen before no I think it's implying that the
dragon crashed here oh okay great got it yeah oh
love it I feel like there's some great camera work
in this really feels like this really realistic
yeah like that's good great job on perspective
oh this fixes ever cut his jugular [Music]
oh you're gonna love this Dragon this dragon
is so cute my high memory remembers one scene
you're gonna love this track it reminds
me of my kitty that's exactly why you're
gonna love this truck exactly like my
kitties I got out your heart and take
it to my father do this I would never
be able to do that chicken you know
[Music]
they made eye contact no
he could sense the animal Aunt I
am this is how Tara got her cats
forgive him he helped you
[Music] yikes whoa awesome
okay not the scene I was thinking of love how
visual that scene was yeah when the eyeballs
the eyeballs just starts off so scared and
you feel like it's a helpless animal then
it reminds you that it could be a ferocious
dragon oh yeah that part and the eyeballs
you go first no no you go first I love other
bodies are so different you get your wish
dragon training you start in the morning
oh man I should have gone first [Laughter]
can't kill dragons but you but you kill dragons no
I'm really very extra sure that I won't it's time
hiccups can you not hear me Father and Son story
carry all of us with you Walk Like Us Talk Like Us
dad's not listening you just gestured to all of
me this conversation is feeling very one-sided
welcome to dragon training no turning back
this feels like a it feels like just a real
movie like a real movie I absolutely knew you
were gonna say that and I was like yeah it does
not just a kiss shots no just everything
and the voiceover specifically I wonder if
they just put lobs in a boom and they just
walk around as if you're in this scene the
script too feels like a real it doesn't feel
like make this for children you know yeah
killed a Night Fury so does that
disqualify him you're small and
you're weak that'll make you less of a
Target all this unintentional insults
11 stealth times two the Monstrous
okay aren't you gonna teach us first I believe
in landling on the job cool if you get blasted
that quick what's the first thing you're going
to need a doctor plus five speed a shield go
Astrid is the [__] I mean that's a chubby
Dragon I'd just be like food and throw it to
him blur it with food make lots of it throw off on
Dragon's aim all dragons have a limited number of
shots oh interesting wow but there's always
sounds happening that's one for each of you
how many kids die in training on day
one they're Vikings they're vicious
laughs pick up oh okay
oh wow yep a dragon will always go
for the kill will it we've learned
otherwise in the forest by ourselves with
the most adorable dragon that ever lived
he does have like that scientist
curious mindset huh yeah because
he's like also just skinny and weak yeah
he's like Oppenheimer yeah totally he's
gonna use the dragon to create
an atomic bomb on its Firebird
oh no
what's wrong with that he's done made
it stupid now Tara oh no go help him
we have the hiccup go wrong he's never
where he should be you need to live and
breathe this stuff everything we know about
every Dragon we know of you don't know enough
me read while we're still
alive the words tell you stuff
now so I guess we'll read it what a fun way to
make fun of youthful modern Viking personality
a bunch of teens with so much angst so it's
really a story about him challenging himself
but his father wants him to be and his history
too yeah when startled the thunder drum produces
a concussive sound that can kill a man at close
range well kill on sight Timberjack here has razor
sharp wings that can slice through full-grown
trees kill on sight every every one of them
has killed yeah yeah even newly hatched dragons
can spray acid kill on site whoa Broncos zipple
back bone knapper Whispering Death wow that's
cool sometimes buries its victims chokes his
victims turns its victims Inside Out whoa dragons
are taking a page out of like Dahmer's book or
something the Unholy offspring of lightning
and death itself hide and prey it does not
find you interesting they're close steady what an
interesting world where everything is just built
around killing dragons sometimes yeah I wonder
like what are what are you guys gonna do once you
kill them all I mean the dragon is on your flag if
they're gone what are you gonna do with your whole
theme are usually like a backdrop in something or
they're like an animal oh my God their boats are
dragon boats yeah it's an interesting world it's
like everything revolves around their identity
with Drake yeah wow their identity that they're
trying to like rid of today it's all about attack
and light on the feet what a black and white Maze
Look for this blind spot every dragon has one
blind spot yes deaf spot not so
much how would one sneak up on
a night fear no one's ever met one
and Left To Tell the tale now get it
Ah that's perfect this looks like
a peacock mixed with a piranha I
feel like all the dragons are based on some
kind of animal yes has anyone ever seen what
happened I love that he's still having this
conversation in the middle of this it's great
oh is this some kind of a joke to
you our parents war is about to
become ours figure out which side
you're on oh man what if he starts
feeding information to the Dragons
It's like a super dark family turn
oh my gosh this is me every time I
walk by my couch with my two cats
toothless could have sworn you have
I don't have any more oh
oh how great this movie
also has amazing music yeah
oh my gosh the breathing and the
look I can't so freaking cute Bond
[Music]
s
I cannot stand how adorable this whole thing
is right now oh my God that was perfect [Music]
awesome
oh you're the way he does that what's that
called like a little like making biscuits yes yes
[Music]
oh my goodness hell yeah
I love him what's he doing
oh
Wowzer cool
[Music]
touch him yeah give him a little pet
oh how beautiful
oh [Music] movies usually model certain mystical
creatures after like dogs or something yeah
he's got to figure out how to build him a
tail how to build a tail for Your Dragon
[Music]
cool
awesome okay so he was just like
a full-on inventor he's so smart
blacksmith but he's a full-on inventor it's okay
yeah oh he's out of fish you're out
of luck buddy hurry make it quick
oh I can feel it he's got his flights back
so fun come on yeah there you go cool
oh my gosh that's amazing I did it
[Laughter]
no he doesn't it like doesn't work without him on
there the Hideous simple back one head breathes
gas the other hand lights it whoa racer sharp
serrated teeth that inject venom for pre-digestion
prefers Ambush attack question its victims
could you please stop that chances of survival
are dwindling into single digits now is that
Christopher mint's Paws I don't know like Lovin
[Music]
oh that one's fire get out of there oh
what tricks have you learned hiccup
oh my God think about what you've done he's
like I love that like Chris Pratt with blue
foreign [Laughter]
[Applause]
yikes oh man no
wow
oh so cute it's like what's he doing
he's beating the dragons with love oh so cute
so cool
cool oh that is awesome it's really cool how
we became a Dragon Rider by accident yeah
hi Astrid hi Astrid
oh my god oh and they're off there's like an
actual like tension to him getting caught you
know yeah because I'm like please don't hurt
him everyone is so relieved by the old and then
with the new right no one will miss that oldness
Village in the life of a celebrity he's very rough
he can barely walk through the village without
being swarmed by his new van it really is a
beautiful story yeah I just don't want him to get
caught in them to be like we gotta kill it because
it's a Night Fury like it's there's so much
wonder and Discovery it's filled with curiosity
[Music]
I'm gonna go this is beautiful she was like Avatar
also feels like Soren the ride at Disneyland
[Music]
stay you got you gotta memorize that
and now you just got to go off intuition
[Applause]
oh that is horrifying yeah oh
yeah the mountain oh oh whoa
wow whoa oh man
yeah just forget it there we go Instinct wow oh
that is cool oh damn I got like chills everywhere
that was awesome [Music] oh there it is come
on [Laughter] Ah that's great yeah there's
like actual like weight and Dynamics to the
animation the physicality of it yeah you know
not so fireproof on the inside are you there you
go oh my God he's friends with all the dragons
oh oh my gosh they all behave
like cats I love them so much
little kitty dragons just got to earn
their trust and love like a cat yeah
everything happens on this island
I would never make a statement like that I was
hoping for this I almost gave up
on you and all the while you are
you are oh no oh boy
oh God heartbreaking
they have something to talk about man in the ring
oh man it just creates more of a distance
between them it's half of her breastplate
[Music]
God what is he gonna do it's so nuanced it's
like the dad feels proud of him but somehow
it just creates more of a distance
between yeah I knew it I was like oh
he's gonna be there and like he's gonna be
like what are you doing this time for sure
do your thing okay girl yeah great
he did it so later oh not so fast
I'm kind of always I hate it the Elder is decided
[Applause] no yes I can't wait I am
so leaving Oh I thought they're gonna
yeah make him do it right then is he still there
oh man oh so you got me it's time everyone
knew drag me back go ahead that's so great
friend oh man Astrid toothless
you wouldn't want to find out more
information yeah wouldn't you want to
be like how you cuddled up next to him
he's not eating you [Music] [Laughter]
now get me down toothless down gently
nothing to be afraid of [Laughter] I love it
I love it he's not usually like this oh no
oh no [Music] [Laughter]
he's emotional man I'm sorry just get me off of
this thing oh that's all I needed here [Music]
oh that's cool how transcending
there should be a ride somewhere
yeah they should build like a mechanical
Dragon we could ride yeah in the clouds
talk about perspective whoa that makes me dizzy
oh my goodness that's beautiful
he's getting lost in the magic that's what the
dragons do man they drug you with their flight
[Music]
this movie communicates so much just
right yeah it's a whole story about
just like enhancing your point of view and
changing your perspective opening your eyes
understanding it's pretty great like to see her
homework her hometown from that point of view
what now we continue killing
dragons and keep them hidden
tomorrow no toothless ain't down with
that you can't be killing no dragons
oh evil dragons oh
oh my [__] goodness it looks like they're
hauling in their kill I don't know what's
happening I remember they're not bad dragons
I don't know what's happening right I'm like
oh they're flying in like a pack right so
it's like Fury just or toothless Blends in
Mordor
oh the nest they were they were looking for
the nest oh yeah I feel like his toothless
heard what she said and maybe decided
like I'm gonna kill you I have to show
you because then maybe you won't oh it's
satisfying to know that all of our food
has been dumped down a hole they're
not eating any of it interesting huh
whoa oh they serve the master the
master dragon we gotta get out
of here all right let's go upstairs oh
that's a good looks like a T-Rex dragon
it's like a giant beehive they're the workers
and that's their Queen it controls them so the
dragons are bad when controlled is that what
they're saying the thing we've been after since
Vikings first sailed here and you want to keep
it a secret to protect your pet dragon are you
serious yes I think she's saying yeah they're
controlled by the big dragon right so they're
only doing bad things to get the thing for the
big guy okay so yeah that's the reason they're
at war with the human okay I got it give
me until tomorrow I'll figure something out
woke women standing up for getting kidnapped oh
never in a million years do you think he could get
Astrid I like how whatever the way it
behaves around her he doesn't behave
like super shy it's just kind of yeah
himself yeah no one's more surprised
my boy becomes a viking today he becomes
one of us I feel so conflicted conflicted
what do you want me to do well he has to be so
I feel his oh yeah I'm like in his shoes and I
I'm like oh this sucks because like he's been
wanting to hear that from his dad I'm ready
oh the one that's always on fire oh my goodness
there's such a visceral way of
capturing some of these drugs
why I was doing in front of
everyone I'm not one of them
oh you didn't have to say that yeah you
could have just thrown the Hat down buddy
they're not what we think they are we don't
have to kill them I said stop the fight
does that have another trick
obviously oh no if you're oh yeah yeah
no don't get hurt toothless no no
damn
no don't you dare oh no no no no no no
don't hurt him oh my God no no
no oh that's no no I don't I hate
it oh my God I hate it oh my God
oh my goodness he was just protecting me they
raid us because they have to there's something
else on their Island dad so you've been to the
nest oh God toothless did only a dragon can find
the island it's not what you think you don't
know what you're up against it's like nothing
you've ever seen okay please oh this is so so
unsettling you throwing your lot in with them
you're not a viking you're not my son yeah some
heartbreaking [__] right there I mean like
that was so harsh but also I'm like oh my God
like parents are like that I mean it'd be like
some parents the way he reacted when the dragon
is attacking his son like he there's no way he
would possibly understand where her son's coming
from like the perspectives make a lot of sense
um and we don't know what happened to
the mom either you know right sounds
like she was killed from the dragon stuff [Music]
oh my God meanie I know it's not making the
dad very likable at all no like now I'm just
like oh yeah I hope your dad dies like what
a jerk I was weak I wouldn't kill a dragon
you said wouldn't that time okay whatever I
wouldn't 300 years and I'm the first Viking
who wouldn't kill a dragon my Stan was what
first to write yeah I would not first the
ride one first the tame a dragon I wouldn't kill
him because he looked as frightened as I was I
probably something stupid
you were wise to seek help from the world's most
deadly weapon yeah it's me I love
this plan I didn't you're crazy
what is the plan train another dragon
and fly it to the hive I mean hiccup
could have really emphasized
more of what he saw too yeah
we're here wow that sound design is terrifying
you're gonna need something to help you hold on
oh my God they're all friends now no
matter how this ends it ends today
[Applause]
man the stubbornness on this thanks
that was an amazing shot
oh now they're like learning they're not there to
like they see a bunch of you and
they're not trying to kill you
this isn't over form your ranks hold together
yeah good luck get clear
whoa what is that whoa
it really does have like a dinosaur aesthetic yeah
whoa whoa oh yeah I mean your whole village
can be dead in one breath okay well no no no
no no somebody let him go I could buy them a
few minutes if I give that thing summertime
then I can double that time give something a
hunt you guys will be haunted in a second baby
that's right as all as it mentions too
to compliment fish legs break it down
compassion and crushing steer clear oh it's
coming into play that's cool left legs hang
in his blind spot Make Some Noise keep it confused
rough tough find out if it's shot limits make it
mad oh that's so neat I love it he's become
a leader that is so clever the subtle way
of showing how he becomes like his dad but in a
very different way yeah it's a very nuanced movie
um it's got multiple as you can see
multiple places at once hold on hold on
it's working yeah it's working oh no
it's affecting all the other dragons too
oh my goodness no
what the hell oh no
no toothless
[Music]
son of a [__] hey season two yeah
this room is badass it's so good I'm
sorry good for everything yeah yeah as
you should be you don't have to go up
there or Vikings it's an occupational
hazard I'm proud to call you my son
whoa yeah
wow whoa I really don't want to capture this
like a monster probably tamale oh he's gonna
blow fire in his mouth because they don't do
well with that ah get Astrid oh did you get her
his room is so moving it's like a perfect movie
damn those shots are incredible
whoa where'd he shoot him I don't know just
like on the outer blast was just strong enough
oh that is terrifying I bet you he's just
gonna try to guide him away right because
like this dude's also a dragon unless he's just
like an evil one wow that's awesome [Music]
time to disappear whoa oh yeah that big
guy can't get up there like that it's
such a weight like you could tell
her yeah so so much happier yeah
oh my goodness [Applause] [Music]
perfect shot you're in my territory now
that's awesome it looks like
lightning like a thunderstorm
yeah this does a lot of great
stuff with the elements watch out
okay time's up let's see if this
works what dude this is what works
wow whoa so imposing whole toothless
hub one more time maybe oh I did it man
that capturing scale whoa whoa that was massive
these flight sequences are incredible no no no no
no
no no no no uh what [Music]
I mean the dragons are all gathered oh
he's probably protecting him what
if he's holding him in his wing
yes yes [Music]
oh my God oh my toothless looked at
him like what are you crying about
thank you for saving my son
most of them most of them
that's like my cat's at six in the
morning after going to bed at three
in the morning yeah [Laughter] I'm in my house
I love it foreign [Music] oh did he lose like a
lake or something why did they say most of them
they're like matching he doesn't have
a wing and now he doesn't have a leg
realization you have to deal with see that
in an average movie something
like that that's crazy do not
oh he has to teach him just oh but he
could like hook it he could hook up yeah
oh my God that picture makes me like want to
cry because it's like it shows the back of
them and without like his wing and him
with his like new yeah it's beautiful
oh how it should be he changed the world yeah
or this island he changed the silence turns out
all we needed was a little worth this you're just
gestured all of me [Music] the Zuri's got so much
[__] art man it's a great callback that's
for scaring me I'll lay one on him [Music]
oh cool amazing oh my oh my God I hated it
are the pets while other places have ponies or
parrots visuals are phenomenal yep we have dragons
wow what a great flip on everything what a great
flip it really is the second coming of Christ
oh my God like literally this movie gave me all
the feels and I'm like uh it's a perfect it's a
perfect movie yeah like literally no notes they
did everything right when when it started off
because all the only thing I really remembered was
when he's first bonding I had like a slight visual
of when it's behaving like a cat yeah that's all I
remember yeah and and so I was like and I remember
it was called toothless so I was like all right
Toothless in the cat moment and that Craig Fergus
and then and that his dad was played by Gerard
Butler but like the whole Arc and all that stuff
like none of that was this whole thing about
like a dragon hive mind thingy oh yeah I don't
know no no the all absent in my brain uh and when
it started off I was like okay this is fun I over
I don't if it don't had slowed down after the big
dress it would slow down after like the whole like
crazy opening it just instantly started becoming
this like amazing film yeah like swept over me
uh right away and then when you see where it
oh my God visual consultant Roger deakins no
wonder looks so you Roger deacons is no he's like
a classic I probably should one of the greatest
cinematographers of all time what else has he
shot like we know where to begin here let me let
me show you oh that makes a lot of sense I just
want you to react to his IMDb for a second he's
like one of the greatest cinematographers of all
some say he is the greatest cinematographer of
all time no wonder though the as I was like
man the camera work on this is so good yeah
um Roger deacons let's go to it oh Blade Runner
okay oh No Country for all men 1917 shot up oh
he's I mean he is he's a god he's a cinema God he
works with the best man oh wow oh True Grit wow
serious man that's a great um beautiful holy
junk Jarhead is such a good movie I need to
re-watch that his fish all Shank Redemption oh my
you shut the Big Lebowski no he's a he's mean you
guys Roger deacons I mean it's funny like I don't
tend to look up the the DPS I mean I should but
um that's amazing he's one he's absolutely one
of the best like cinematographers of all time is
um I feel like looking at that he is yeah so I I
love this movie a lot like the but the thing is
like by the time they get to that ending moment
with the by the time he gets the ending moment
what when they're bringing back the narration and
saying like all of you going okay then that first
few minutes was perfect it was like absolutely
worth it then yeah because it sets up all the
the great callback right like the Arc of it all
yeah and I also love that they arced back to like
the the best thing about this place is the pets
where it's now they they are pets living in this
world where before it's funny where they were just
like we're Vikings and we kill and now the world
is is so different now they have pets and I'm like
yeah pets really do do that like you get a pet and
you're like my world's so different now that I got
a pet like what was I doing before not having one
like I wasn't really living and I think too the
relationship between Hiccup and stoic what a funny
name Hiccup and stoic because they don't have this
exchange of dialogue at the end of I'm sorry if
he says I'm just sorry they just say I'm sorry
to each other right but it's never like I'm
sorry for not listening to you there's not this
big monologue of apologies and and Exposition
dumping your character arcs and the relationship
Arc they have they they just have like a little
bit of an exchange of I'm sorry and it's the
looks they exchange and then of course the visual
representation of the drag is being welcome the
gesturing to yeah all of you um that understanding
that they can never have with each other because
it's it's such a father and son tale and it's got
all these themes about perspective and lineage
and opening your mind hard up there's all these
different nuances that are just laced throughout
I thought it was I I saw it I I definitely didn't
um before but this this was like this really hit
like this is a brilliant film I mean I heard the
sequels are like just as amazing just as good
or if not better holy people people I know some
people who say it's like there it is arguably
the best Trilogy one of the best trilogies of
all time wow so yeah I hear they're great that's
insane also like at the end when he's like I'm
proud to call you my son it's like during the
entire movie all he's hiccup is fighting for is
to hear that and for him to actually finally
hear it in in a way that he wants to without
it being said of him faking his way through it
being like I'll be a viking and I'm gonna kill
this thing and I'll fake it and then like dad
says he's proud but then I have to live with
like oh the pain of it it was like no it was done
in a really nice way where they didn't I feel like
they didn't waste time going through a bunch
of stuff that you may assume the tropes that
we would have to like hoop through to make the
relationship harder between son and father so
the payback is bigger at the end I'm like the
payback was just as big and we got still a lot
of time of Hiccup training the dragons teaching
his friends that hey it's okay and we didn't need
uh more scenes of like him and the dad and the
dad being like upset or making him like kill
a dragon it was just the right amount to give us
like enough of that juice so that the end is quite
the payoff which I really enjoy but man I mean my
favorite part of that is that he lost his leg and
now he is like his Dragon like the similarities
in that I love that I think it's really great
writing yeah and I think it's just adorable the
visual mirroring and symbolism is really strong
yeah it's a deep film with with fairies and it's
it this is like the definition of accessible for
the whole families we're not like I can take my
kids to go watch it and I can muster through it
you know right sit through it it it's something
that truly is like yeah if you're a kid I could
totally see you loving this movie and if you're
an adult you could I think you could pick up
on all these nuances and details where it's
like this to me is like a truly a cinematic
experience yeah I mean there's like differences
in when he's like this is your mother's half
breastplate on the hat yeah that's an adult joke
that kids are not gonna get where you're like uh
that's funny like there's little stuff like that
with in the writing that is not like they're not
going to be like we're hitting a a home with like
the kiddos it's like the kids are just gonna like
watching this and understand what's going on right
it's simple as like he's got to train that dragon
that uh keep it cool hopefully nobody else kills
the dragon how is he gonna get through that well
the characters like can still be like big and
domineering but the kids don't even I mean you
could watch this movie on mute and be like I
like it yeah like you know yeah well they they
illustrate the dragons in a way that feels very
kid-friendly but I love when they get to whatever
Queen dragon is at the end yeah that it feels
truly monstrous yes like there's such a great
sense of peril and it's harrowing the stakes
are really high and it it the whole thing gets
obscured in darkness by the end yeah and and the
way the characters all come around to each other
even even like with Astrid you know like the A
lot changes via through action and not so much
just through dialogue words yeah right like with
Astrid he directly says like let me just show you
instead of trying to talk you into it right and
they go on a magic dragon right and you know and
then on the Magic Dragon right she's she under
she gets it like she understands it right then
and there and then even the dad all he had to
do is see them all riding together and saving
the day and like oh I get it now you know I think
this is a great for for an animation especi which
is a visual medium and nowadays they do a lot
of you know kids movies animated that that
don't really rely on just visual storytelling and
while it doesn't only rely on visual storytelling
I think they have a Perfect Blend where the nice
bound they are taking advantage of their medium
to communicate a lot just through the visuals
where so much emotion is felt via just through
the visuals yeah I agree I also think that him
at the final part of him teaching his friend he's
now found his tribe they're like his friends
and they respect him and he's become more of
a leader like you said like his dad which is cool
yeah which is awesome but then he he has to go up
by himself a toothless up into the clouds to like
kill this most giant dinosaur ever and he does it
all on his own just by himself so it's like in
in turn he has become the greatest leader uh and
he he does have to kill a dragon which is like
the whole point in the beginning it does yeah
and it's funny that he he also has to do it you
know the irony of on top of a dragon that he loves
and that he trained well yeah exploring the gray
though the nuances like not all dragons are bad
right uh totally that is very neat and Toothless
is just amazing like God I just want to do let's
just remind you my cats yes I mean that's why you
were like you're gonna like this but yes it was
because they still keep him like a dragon he's
not just a cat he's like cat and a dragon combined
like he's flying around my life that's a cat right
there you know but when he's on ground he's a cat
yes and and the the loyalty and and um the sense
of comfort too and the way that it likes to be
loved yeah and a lot of the behavioral traits of
being a little bit Petty or snarky I think there's
a lot of cuteness to him and yes of course the
real heart of the movie is the relationship with
two between them oh my God but one my other
favorite shot is when the dragon is trying to
smile and he's like oh yeah yeah he's like shaking
oh my God that I just I love everything about this
movie for me I nine out of ten I mean forget
about it if y'all are like the the other ones
are even better uh okay this movie was I loved it
I really really did I like it the last thing I'll
say is like the music too it's very sweeping oh
yeah and different though like when you said this
has really good music it's I wasn't even picking
up on it at all until he said something it was in
the very first scene when he when he spits up the
the other half of the fish right and it was very
different it's not like an atypical Orchestra type
of a sound it has like I don't know especially
in that scene and then for the rest of it yeah it
probably did but in that one specific scene it was
different and it totally worked and I really liked
it that's part of the maturity element I think too
to the movie is like the music doesn't feel like
a bunch of high notes kids music yeah or is it
like trying to be like always heavy adult music or
something like that but it will you know yeah yeah
I feel like not noticing it but also feeling the
sweeping motions of it like when they're flying uh
without the music trying to the music didn't need
to pull your emotions into what was happening on
screen because what was happening on screen you
were already there with the way the movie is but
you know how there's some where you're like the
music and the thing really yeah yeah trying to
force it in there yes and this one didn't didn't
do that and above all an animation sometimes an
animated properties at voiceover work especially
you can when you're hearing a certain voice you
could I don't I don't quite know sometimes it does
the matching you kind of feel like they got I feel
like they really animated around the voice I
agree like I'm Blended so well I was kind of
thinking like did they just go why don't you guys
just sit here and do this scene it felt like they
were almost there right yeah and we'll just like
kind of animate around how they gesture and speak
yeah it felt like they were in the same which is
not I don't know if that's the case but it really
got the impression because like Gerard Butler
plays the Dad and the way the scene the scenes
would go down I I the blend of it because Jonah
Hill is one of them Jay baruchel's the lead and
these are voice actors that I've heard in other
stuff but it always sounds like oh I hear Jay
bearish show oh I hear Jonah Hill yeah but here
I just saw the characters yeah you know and and
I think that's uh especially when you're getting
like celebrity voices usually you just see this
you hear the celebrity absolutely and this one
not really until I was like I was really trying
to figure out Jonah Hill for like the first 30
minutes of this movie and then I was like Jonah
Hill yeah uh in my brain and I didn't say it out
loud but uh for the rest of them I yeah I mean I
think you're right by like minute 25 you're like
you're in and you're flying it's going you're like
this is a great film yes and then the first 20
minutes yeah it's like some foundational setup
stuff yeah which is still good and entertaining
but yes once he gets the tooth it's one yeah
once he gets to toothless it's we're off and we're
running that's when you're like oh this is a this
is something different yeah way different like
I love it so much we should want you guys can
let us know I mean do you have any last thoughts
gregory no I've had like many last thoughts the
last 10 minutes sorry we love this movie so much
comment let us know what you guys think uh we love
you so much don't forget if you want to be a super
sexy person join patreon and I think we're gonna
do a shout out let's do it Tyler Hague if there
is anyone at our patreon page who I would want
to ride through the skies it'd be you oh you're
cuddly man there's something about you that just
makes me feel so warm and fuzzy on the inside
that I think riding through the skies with you
would feel like I'm right in first class my friend
that's so sweet and then I could take Tara on the
back of me yeah he would make me fly in coach for
sure I would yeah yeah Tyler's been large enough
for there could be different I feel like Tyler
is like he's gonna be like nope I'm an all-class
person and Tara is if she's flying coach she's
not even with us anymore no exactly we'd have you
got it coaches in his butt got it
coaches his butt which is still comfy
depending upon what you ate that day but yeah
Tyler's got a great butt yeah and does he work
out a lot is it like tough or is it soft and
smooshy like a plush or like firm mattress
it's like a plush plush okay I'm good with I'm
good with flush but he eats a lot of burritos
I think that I would like to cancel
the trip all together no refunds okay
I can handle it I mean I've handled gas I mean
I've seen the kind of menu updated [Laughter]
I think you can handle Towers but first for
three hours for a three hour flight our flight
to Colorado let me just ask Tyler like do you hook
up media down there like are you able to sneak in
you know USB cord with an iPad little lowly Tara
over here just up the I'm just saying if you got
to shove me up there you got to be having some
devices too just you know like an iPad and like
I I still need like a I'm pretty sure a few
drinks it's gonna be entertaining enough as
it is in this situation I don't really trust me I
don't know just the aroma of sense yeah I mean but
once I get over that it's gonna be like this is
boring well the odds of videos are gonna pass out
I don't know I've smelled my own
farts before they can be pretty
bad ah Tara your attractive points
just went down way far yeah well
it's it's supposed to I mean I thought they
were already really down there I know like I
didn't even know still had uh no it's a dot yeah
exactly it's non-existent try to find it we can't
well well this has been fun Tyler shout out to
Tyler for yeah for just being being around Tyler
good luck with your butt I hope to never
see it or maybe I do well when you didn't
have as many attractive points as you have yeah
you're gonna take what you can get or this one
foreign